sie zählten einmal zu den
fortschrittlichsten orten der welt
mit das modernste was ingenieurs und org
uns zu bieten hatten
dann wurden diese anlagen aufgegeben
manche sind heute lebensgefährlich
verseucht
nur ein fernes echo hallt noch von den
menschen die hier einst lebten und
arbeiteten
was bleibt sind offene fragen und
ungelöste rätsel
warum endet diese prestige projekte also
jenen und geisterstädte
[Musik]
dieser zerstörte luftwaffenstützpunkt
aus dem kalten krieg ist heute eine
ära war war ein geheimnis umworbener
unterirdischer flugzeug hangar auf
dem reißbrett machte ihr anlage sicher
was her lasst uns den stützpunkt tief in
den berg hinein bauen damit keine insel
er sollte vor einer atombombe von
hiroshima typ geschützt seien und
wie wurde aus einer winzigen bergwerks
hin so in japan eine stadt die aus allen
nähten platzte
einer der beengten orte der welt hier
lebten mehr als 5000 leute auf kleinstem
raum
sie konnten die insel durchaus schritten
recht einfach vergrößern denn sie hat
mir den aushub der durch den bergbau an
vier
siegen einen rund 200 meter langen
förderschacht unter dem meer eine
spitzenleistung der bauingenieure
wie wurde eine sowjetische musterstadt
zum sinnbild der apokalypse
[Musik]
die verlassenen stadt pripjat ist ein
modernes pompei
das leben der menschen verwandelte sich
über nacht in einen albtraum
sie ist untrennbar mit der
atomkatastrophe von tschernobyl
verbunden aber ursprünglich verkörperte
die stadt den sowjetischen traum und die
menschen wollten daran teilhaben
und welches ziel verfolgten die nazis
mit dem bau dieser riesigen ferienanlage
prora war ein wichtiger teil der nazi
ideologie
es sollte die gleichschaltung der massen
sicherstellen
gehirnwäsche vom feinsten
[Musik]
im nordosten deutschlands auf der
ostseeinsel rügen liegt eine anlage mit
düsterer vergangenheit
zwischen kiefernwäldern erstreckt sich
ein gigantischer gebäuderiegel entlang
der küste errichtet im auftrag von
hitlers nazi regime
der komplex gehört zu den längsten
gebäuden europas
ein koloss der die malerische landschaft
beherrscht
prora so heißt das monstrum sollte als
ferienanlage tausende deutsche urlauber
gleichzeitig beherbergen
aber der bau diente nach einem anderen
und düsteren zweck
cora war nichts anderes als ein modernes
zentrum für gehirnwäsche die deutschen
arbeiter sollten hier nicht einfach nur
urlaub machen
morgen sollten sie per lautsprecher
installiert werden wie sie ihren tag zu
gestalten hatten es gab gemeinsame
essenszeiten und in der so genannten
freizeit sollten alle gäste die gleichen
propaganda filme und bücher konsumieren
die menge an zeit und geld die die nazis
in den bau von prora investierten zeigt
wie ungeheuer wichtig ihnen dieses
projekt war
sie wollten auf lange sicht einer
herrenrasse schaffen in der alle wie die
nazis dachten
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die historikerin kataloge leitet das
dokumentationszentrum prora
nach ihrer einschätzung war dies nicht
einfach nur eine ferienanlage für
industriearbeiter für die nazis sollte
es noch etwas ganz anderes leisten
[Musik]
ein seebad zu errichten was er so weit
eingeholte
deutschen arbeitern die nicht so viel
geld auf ferien zu haben und auf am mehr
ferien machen zu können
der hintergedanke dabei war dass man
möglichst schnell sich erholen sollte in
möglichst kurzer zeit in
hochkonzentrierter form um fit für den
krieg zu sein um bessere arbeitsleistung
durchführen zu können und eigentlich
auch um fit für massenmord gemacht zu
werden
eine ferienanlage als teil von hitlers
weltherrschaft und völkermord plänen wie
sollte das funktionieren
hinter dem chor la concept stand die
politische organisation kraft durch
freude kdf
geführt vom leiter der deutschen
arbeitsfront robert ley
[Musik]
kdf bot vor allem günstige reisen für
millionen geringverdiener an aber das
eigentliche ziel war die menschen unter
hitler als volksgemeinschaft
zusammenzuschweißen
[Applaus]
die idee von kraft durch freude war das
volk als nazi regime zu binden
wahrscheinlich wollten sie die leute
eine art gehirnwäsche unterziehen und
sie so auf einen möglichen krieg
vorbereiten
[Musik]
kann da war lebensnotwendig für das
dritte reihe
mussten voll und ganz dahinterstehen
cora sollte dafür sorgen dass die leute
voller begeisterung 100 prozent ihrer
freizeit gaben dazu dienten parolen wie
wir sind die größten ist dafür lohnt es
sich zu leiden oder das volk steht
zusammen
mit prora wollte leyen das beliebte kdf
konzept von vergünstigten seereisen und
freizeitaktivitäten noch weiter ausbauen
als kdf seebad rügen sollte die anlage
den arbeitern alles bieten was sie zur
erholung von ihrem knochenjobs in den
rüstungs fabriken trachten schwimmbäder
kino kegelbahnen kneipen und kabarett
sie sollten unermüdlich mit propaganda
berieselt werden
das konzept war seiner zeit weit voraus
die ausstattung war zwar recht
spartanisch aber die anlage wirkte
einfach großartig die mittel zur totalen
kontrolle und manipulation waren
natürlich eingebaut
aber der durchschnittliche deutsche
arbeiter hätte es für das paradies
gehalten viele lebten in
industriestädten und waren noch nie am
meer gewesen was für eine attraktion die
urlauber sollten hinterher rufen
da war sicher eine gehörige portion
nationalismus dabei
[Musik]
wir sehen hier die steinerne vorstellung
von volksgemeinschaft wie die national
so dass sie sich gedacht haben ähnlich
wie auf den kds schützen hätte man
eigentlich von morgens bis abends
programm gehabt mit einem morgenappell
und dann bis hin zum schwimmen im meer
und abendessen und
abschlussveranstaltung wer alles
durchorganisiert gewesen
der viereinhalb kilometer lange regel
war in 86 stöckige blöcke unterteilt
gebaut aus stahlbeton damals noch ein
ausnahme werkstoff in deutschland
die gäste hätten wohl gestaunt stahl
beton hatten sie noch nie zu gesicht
bekommen das war der inbegriff moderner
bautechnik
was wir vielleicht heute für einen
stinkt langweiligen baustoff halten galt
damals als spannende innovation
[Musik]
jedes zimmer sollte mehr willig haben
und einfach ausgestattet sein in prora
ding ist nicht um luxus sondern um macht
[Musik]
die riesigen eingangsbereiche sollten
genauso imposant sein wie das
reichsparteitagsgelände in nürnberg
dieser rolle gehört einfach mit und
verwaltung spart der empfangshalle das
ist so hoch und so mächtig um natürlich
ein dient den arbeiter der hätte
herkommen sollen zu beeindrucken
einzuschüchtern auf diese weise hat man
einfluss genommen mann war
eingeschüchtert und dann war aber
zugleich auch
wenn man bestandteil dieser großen idee
war
so hat manipulationen funktioniert
heute ist prödl und verfallen keine spur
vom glanz der hier erstrahlen sollte
aber die baupläne geben einen eindruck
wie man die arischen herrenrasse hier
demonstrativ in szene setzen wollte
jeder sollte beim besuch denken was für
ein großartiges land
[Musik]
denn wer in den 30er jahren ein bauwerk
wie prora sei der musste beeindruckt
sein jeder deutsche hätte stolz gedacht
das ist wirklich etwas besonderes und es
gehört uns
[Musik]
herzstück des komplexes sollte eine
monumentale festhalle werden mit platz
für alle 20.000 besucher auf einmal
[Applaus]
[Musik]
streng und schlicht gestaltet sollte sie
die überlegenheit der sogenannten
arischen herrenrasse zeigen und
nationalstolz auslösen der effekt war da
riesige festhallen gab es seit
ewigkeiten vor allem die alten römer
verstandenes gut zehntausende menschen
auf relativ kleinem raum unterzubringen
[Musik]
so ein anblick wirkt auf den betrachter
quasi hypnotisierend
psychologische effekte dieser art waren
ganz in hitlers in
der ganze bau hat zwar so nicht
funktioniert wo man sich gedacht hatte
als man ihn errichtet hat aber man sieht
wofür her gedacht war man kann damit
viel erklären man kann die ideologie
damit erklären
nach kriegsende besetzt die rote armee
prora zu ddr-zeiten dient die anlage als
kaserne der drittel traut ist berüchtigt
nach dem mauerfall wird vorrat anfang
der 90er jahre aufgegeben das gebäude
verfällt bis vor kurzem
rund 80 jahre nach dem baubeginn durch
die nazis entstehen hier luxuswohnungen
mit meerblick
[Musik]
mini bringt auch viele hätten den
gesamten komplex lieber dem erdboden
gleichgemacht
sie wollten dass dieses totalitäre
projekt zur gehirnwäsche in der
versenkung verschwindet
der umbau in luxuswohnungen symbolisiert
gewissermaßen den triumph des
kapitalismus und gibt den kdf
werbeplakaten mit dem glücklichen
pärchen nachträglich eine neue bedeutung
[Musik]
was für verrückte sachen mit stahlbeton
anfangen kann zeigt sich auch auf einer
kleinen insel vor der küste japans
südwestlich von nagasaki ihr name
hashima
[Musik]
ende des neunzehnten jahrhunderts ist
sie nur ein schmaler fels kann der aus
dem meer ragt aber die erschließung
eines kohleflöze unter dem meeresgrund
ändert alles
durch landgewinnung wächst diesen so
langsam aber stetig unterkünfte für die
bergleute müssen her wie wurde aus einer
kleinen mine einer der am dichtesten
besiedelten orte der welt und warum
wohnt dort heute niemand mehr
für bauingenieure ist das eine enorme
herausforderung dem meer land
abzutrotzen denn das wasser ist ständig
in bewegung
die flut kommt und geht und dass mehr
wasser zersetzt die baustoffe man
versucht also inmitten dieses
beweglichen mediums massenhaft material
aufzuschichten und ein festes stabiles
fundament zu bauen darauf sollen dann
riesige gebäude errichtet werden
schema china gilt nicht umsonst als
insel ohne grün es war einer der
berühmtesten orte der welt wir lebten
mehr als 5000 menschen auf kleinstem
raum aber sie gewöhnen sich daran wenn
sie das festland besuchten war das für
sie richtig seltsam heutige touristen
haben wir hingegen erzählt dass sie gar
nicht schnell genug von der insel runter
kommen konnten
in japan wird das ein land auch und kann
china oder kriegsschiff in sogenannte
mutter arbeitete im kohlebergwerk bis
1974 stillgelegt wurde er erinnert sich
noch genau an seine erste überfahrt
ich sage insel zum ersten mal vom schiff
aus und fand leicht dass sie einem
kriegsschiff ähnelte
beim anlegen konnte ich nicht viel vom
gelände sehen
erst vom bürofenster aus bekam ich einen
eindruck
die zeche die schächte und die vielen
arbeiter das ist die kohle insel
unter der insel verläuft damals ein sehr
ergiebiges kohleflöz um dorthin zu
kommen muss ein 200 meter langer schacht
gegraben werden die arbeitsbedingungen
tief unter dem meer sind extrem hart
[Musik]
dort unten zu arbeiten war sehr
gefährlich
von der decke fielen oft gesteinsbrocken
es war heiß und stickig als würde man in
einem dampfbad schuf
je mehr kohle auf verschlimmern
gefördert wird desto mehr arbeiter
werden gebraucht aber der platz auf der
insel ist knapp logistisch eine enorme
herausforderung
in china ich halte china für eine
spitzenleistung der bauingenieure in den
meeresgrund bei der insel trieben sie
einen 200 meter tiefen schacht und dann
stellte sich die frage wo soll das alles
hin was sich aus der mine hole wie
können wir es lagern auf der insel ist
hier kein platz dafür
also musste die kohle auf schiffe
geladen um zum festland transportiert
werden aber können die schiffe auch in
china anlegen es war ein riesiges
logistikprobleme und ich finde es wurde
auf hashima extrem gut gelöst
was mich an hashima so umhaut ist dass
die insel sich quasi aus sich selbst
heraus vergrößert hat je tiefer man in
der mine gräbt desto mehr aushub bekommt
man und den kann man ganz landgewinnung
nutzen die fläche der insel wird größer
und man kann noch mehr kumpel
unterbringen und die fördern wiederum
noch mehr kohle und immer so weiter
im laufe der jahre kommen immer mehr
arbeiter nach china das aufgeschüttete
landwirt mit einer betonmauer gegen
stürme und fluten gesichert
[Musik]
stahlbeton war wie geschaffen um so eine
kleine insel zu bebauen
sie hatten nicht genug platz um viele
verschiedene baustoffe auf der insel zu
lagern also gossen sie einfach nach
bedarf stahlbeton und fertig
[Musik]
besonders überrascht war ich von den
mehrstöckigen wohnblöcken aus stahlbeton
ich hatte nicht damit gerechnet dass auf
dieser kleinen insel so viele häuser
stehen würden sie waren überall
[Musik]
es ist sehr knifflig hochhäuser direkt
neben einer mine zu bauen unter der erde
gehen dinge vor sich die man mit
einkalkulieren muss man untergräbt mit
den stollen ihres fundament auf dem
später große gebäude stehen soll der
bergbau bedroht die standfestigkeit und
da ein stabiles und sicheres fundament
zu errichten ist keine leichte aufgabe
stahl beton hat an einem ort wie china
aber noch einen vorteil er ist feuerfest
wenn man ein kohlebergwerk betreibt ist
das ideal
ende der fünfziger jahre erreicht die
einwohnerzahl von hashima den höchsten
stand mehr als 5000 menschen leben auf
einer fläche so groß wie neuen
fußballfelder und fördern jedes jahr
hunderttausende tonnen kohle
minoru kinoshita wurde auf china geboren
und erinnert sich noch gut an seine
kindheit
die insel war voller menschen
so viele dass man es sich kaum
vorstellen kann aber trotzdem war das
nicht chaotisch
wir lebten in hausnummer 30
wir waren zu viert in meiner familie und
wir lebten alle zusammen in einem raum
er war extrem klein
[Musik]
trotz der beengten verhältnisse
arrangieren sich die bewohner der insel
mit ihrer außergewöhnlichen
lebenssituation
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es gab einen kindergarten eine
grundschule eine mittelschule ein
krankenhaus eine spielhalle eine bar
einen friseur und einen blumenladen
[Musik]
in den hochhäusern gab es keine
fahrstühle die
häuser waren auf mehreren stockwerken
durch brücken miteinander verbunden so
dass du nicht erst ganz nach unten gehen
musstest um in ein anderes haus zu
kommen
man konnte einfach zu den anderen
aparten uns rüber gehen
[Musik]
die lebensverhältnisse auf china waren
sicher grenzwertig bei der planung wurde
offenbar nicht berücksichtigt dass
menschen auch dringend genügend
rückzugsräume brauchen um sich
wohlzufühlen
[Musik]
china sollte funktionieren sonst nichts
es ging nur um die effizienz der arbeit
ich glaube nicht dass man viel weiter
darüber hinaus gedacht hat ist
tot
[Musik]
eine belastung auch für die kinder der
insel aber selbst in dieser fast
unmenschlichen enge finden sie platz zum
spielen not macht eben erfinderisch
die kinder waren extrem einfallsreich
sie spielten karten auf den stufen und
mit murmeln in winzigen ecken
jeder winkel wurde als spielplatz
genutzt selbst die dächer
[Musik]
wir haben unsere eigene methode
entwickelt um baseball auf der insel
spielen zu können
dafür haben wir uns wirklich das hirn
zermartert
ein problem ist auch die versorgung der
bewohner lebensmittel kleidung alles was
die menschen brauchen muss vom festland
aus angeliefert werden
in 84 betriebsjahren werden auf rund 16
millionen tonnen kohle gefördert
aber dann gehen die vorkommen zur neige
und japan setzt mehr auf erdöl
1974 wird die zeche stillgelegt
die arbeiter und ihre familien verlassen
die insel so schnell es geht zurück
bleibt ein ort der aussieht als wären
die bewohner vor einer apokalypse
geflohen er erinnert an eine andere
stadt viele tausend kilometer entfernt
die stadt pripjat in der ukraine war
einst der stolz der sowjetunion
[Musik]
entworfen auf dem reißbrett ein
verheißungsvoller ort für die zukunft
einer jungen generation
so war der plan
drittens sollte hoch moderne unterkünfte
und beste infrastruktur für die
mitarbeiter des benachbarten
atomkraftwerks tschernobyl bieten
heute liegt die stadt verlassen zwischen
kiefernwäldern in einer sperrzone streng
bewacht von sicherheitskräften
ein mahnmal dafür wie aus einer
zukunftsvision ein albtraum werden kann
das verlassene probiert ist ein modernes
pompei das leben der menschen wurde über
nacht auf den kopf gestellt
über einen park wo sich die menschen
amüsieren sollten ragt ein leeres
riesenrad auf den straßen sieht man
verlassene spielgeräte stumme zeugen
einer hastigen fluchtartigen evakuierung
es passierte blitzschnell und es war
fürchterlich
am 26 april 1986 explodiert im
atomkraftwerk tschernobyl ein reaktor
block
radioaktives material wird in die
atmosphäre geschleudert ein riesiges
gebiet im umkreis des kraftwerks auch im
benachbarten russland und weißrussland
wird verseucht und die radioaktive wolke
zieht weiter über europa auch dort
stellten die strahlungswerte dramatisch
an
[Musik]
ironischerweise ist der ort heute eine
überaus beliebte touristenattraktion
das liegt sicher an der faszination des
morbiden wir kennen so was seit
jahrzehnten aus billigen
katastrophenfilmen aber dort kann man
sich in der realen welt anschauen was
passiert wenn es zum schlimmsten kommt
[Musik]
die entfernung zwischen kredit- und
tschernobyl beträgt nur etwas mehr als
drei kilometer zur zeit der katastrophe
leben fast 50.000 menschen in der stadt
für uns ist pripjat heute in erster
linie ein katastrophenort der untrennbar
mit dem schrecklichen atom unfall vor
seiner haustür in tschernobyl verbunden
ist
[Musik]
aber man muss sich auch anschauen wie
das leben vorher in der stadt war
[Musik]
die bilder die sich uns ins gedächtnis
eingebrannt haben das verfallene
riesenrad und die herumliegenden
gasmasken sie erzählen nur einen teil
der geschichte vor der katastrophe lief
es in der stadt blendend es war der
sowjetische traum vom fortschritt und
die leute wollten daran teilhaben
regiert wird
1970 als wohnort für die arbeiter des
neuen atomkraftwerks tschernobyl
gegründet sie soll eine vorzeigestadt
der sowjetunion seien ein symbol für die
friedliche nutzung der atomenergie und
ein musterbeispiel für moderne stadtteil
der touristenführer sergej chernoff kam
als junger mann nach pripjat für ihn war
es ohne zweifel eine stadt der zukunft
[Musik]
hat wurde nie ganz fertig gestellt
alles war bis ins detail geplant
eine buchstäblich blühende stadt
so viele rosen und kinder hatte ich
zuvor noch nie an einem ort gesehen
[Musik]
das riesige gelände das ihnen zur
verfügung stellt nutzen die stadtplaner
in den siebziger jahren ausgiebig
zwischen den hochhäusern werden gärten
und parks angelegt da die bevölkerung
größtenteils jünger als 30 jahre alt ist
gibt es auch viele sportanlagen
[Musik]
das herz von pripjat schlägt damals am
hauptplatz
[Musik]
das hier ist der hauptplatz das gebäude
dort vorne war der kulturpalast
energetik
rechts davon steht ein ehemaliges hotel
es hieß policia und war zur zeit der
explosion hochmoderne
da drüben auf dem fünfstöckigen haus ist
ein slogan angebracht er lautet lasst
das atom einen arbeiter seien um keinen
soldaten
[Musik]
die neue stadt wird als triumph des
sozialismus gefeiert bald können die
bewohner an ihrer arbeitsplätze der
erste reaktor des atomkraftwerks
tschernobyl geht
1977 ans netz drei weitere blöcke folgen
bis 1983
aber am 26 april 1986 um 1 uhr 23 nachts
wird es zukunft jäh zerstört
reaktor nummer 4 ist explodiert und
schleudert radioaktive teilchen über
weite teile europas zwei weitere
reaktoren sind stillgelegt worden dass
es der größter atomunfall der geschichte
die explosion im reaktorblock 4 setzt
enorme strahlung frei doch die
bevölkerung von privat wird nicht
gewarnt
zahlreiche beschäftigte des kraftwerks
sowie feuerwehrleute erkranken bereits
wenige stunden nach der havarie
aber die evakuierung der stadt wird erst
einen tag später angeordnet
hunderte busse und lastwagen sammeln die
leute ein man sagt ihnen sie würden in
wenigen tagen zurück kommen
tatsächlich wird es ein abschied für
immer
die extrem breiten straßen in privat-
sowie die großzügig angelegten plätze
erleichterten die evakuierung erheblich
innerhalb weniger stunden wurde die
gesamte bevölkerung fast 50.000 menschen
aus der stadt geholt
die über jahrzehnte gewachsen sind mit
kleinen gassen und nebenstraßen wäre das
wesentlich schwieriger gewesen ein mords
problem
aber dank der übersichtlichen
infrastruktur war es möglich einen
detaillierten evakuierungsplan zu
erstellen die breiten straßen waren die
hauptverkehrsadern über die der
abtransport effizient durchgeführt
werden konnte
nicht nur die menschen ausprobiert
müssen ihr zuhause verlassen alle orte
im radius von 30 kilometern um den
unglücksreaktor werden evakuiert später
wird die sperrzone auf über 4000
quadratkilometer ausgeweitet
[Musik]
rund 1300 kilometer südwestlich von
tschernobyl steht ein bollwerk des
kalten krieges gefeit gegen die atomare
apokalypse aber nicht gegen einen
bürgerkrieg
[Applaus]
[Musik]
in den 50er jahren laufenden auf westen
jugoslawiens arbeiten für ein streng
geheimes bauprojekt eines der größten
und teuersten in europa die menschen in
der abgelegenen region bei wie hutch
haben keine ahnung dass vor ihrer nase
eine flugzeug kaverne entsteht ein
unterirdischer hangar sein name java
auf dem reißbrett machte die anlage
sicher was her lasst uns den stützpunkt
tief in den berg hinein bauen damit
keiner hinsieht
[Musik]
so ungewöhnlich war dieser plan gar
nicht ähnliche projekte gab es auch in
anderen teilen europas vor allem in der
schweiz und in italien
und russen und us amerikaner nutzten im
kalten krieg gehärtete unterstände sie
dachten das würde nicht nur ihre
flugzeuge sondern auch ihre taktischen
atomwaffen schützen
[Musik]
der ingenieur und fotograf tom lesch
kennt sich mit stillgelegten
militärstützpunkten aus er hat sich
vilja war ganz genau angeschaut
während des kalten krieges war dieser
luftwaffenstützpunkt zur abschreckung
gedacht gegen einen erstschlag auch von
den sowjets oder dem westen
[Musik]
deshalb wurde er in dieser
abgeschiedenen gegend gebaut im süden
bot der werkschutz und über die
hochebene im norden hatte man gute sicht
luft verbände unterirdisch zu
stationieren ist eigentlich eine gute
idee aber in gioia war brauchte man 20
jahre im nur drei kilometer tunnel in
den berg zu bohren
der eckpfeiler der jugoslawischen
luftabwehr seien fünf start und
landebahnen werden gebaut jede über zwei
kilometer lang drei jagd staffeln sollen
von hier aus operieren kann
aber als der tunnelbau beginnt stoßen
die ingenieure schnell auf probleme
bei den bohrungen entdeckten sie zu
ihrer überraschung natürliche kavernen
und höhlen im fels sie hatten wohl
massives gestein erwartet jetzt hatten
sie ein problem wie soll man durch so
einen cast einen stabilen tunnel bauen
die ursprünglichen pläne mussten also
geändert werden sie brauchten für die
tunnel in den hohlräumen eine art
aufhängen
die ingenieure lernten ständig dazu um
den berg im innern zu stabilisieren und
die risiken stollen für all ihre
flugzeuge bauen zu können setzten sie
stahlbeton
hangars für bis zu 80 mit kampfflugzeuge
werden in den fels getrieben hinzu
kommen eine kommando- sowie eine radar
zentrale lager für generatoren bomben
und kerosin sowie unterkünfte für mehr
als 1000 soldaten
der clou sind aber vorrichtungen die vor
einer atombombenexplosion schützen
sollen
der ganze vorstellen ist eine art
schutzraum der rechtwinklig um die ecke
biegt dadurch sollte die explosions
energie eine atombombe verpuffen bevor
sie in den hauptstollen bringen kann
hier oben sieht man die beton
schlitzwände die druckwelle ableiten
sollten die mechanischen schutz anlage
befindet sich am ende dieses gekrümmten
tunnels ein 100 tonnen schweres panzer
tour aus stahlbeton
wenn man seine luftstreitkräfte unter
der erde stationiert sind sie zwar vor
direkten angriffen und bombardements
geschützt dafür sorgt der riesige berg
von oben aber wenn es in der nähe der
stollen eingänge zu einer explosion
kommt kann die druckwelle durch die
tunnel direkt zu den flugzeugen gelenkt
werden die man eigentlich schützen will
im ernstfall wäre julia war vermutlich
komplett von der außenwelt abgeschnitten
die vorräte reichen aus um tausend
menschen einen monat lang zu versorgen
der stützpunkt soll einer sprengkraft
von 20 kilotonnen tnt äquivalent
standhalten können das entspricht der
atombombe die in nagasaki zerstört hatte
die flugzeuge waren hinter diesen panzer
toren aufgereiht wenn eins von ihnen
starten sollte wurde es zum anfang der
startbahn gezogen und flog von dort los
die tore hatten eine umgekehrte t form
[Musik]
sie waren extra für kampfflugzeuge mit
einem einzelnen seitenleitwerk wie eine
mig 21 gebaut solche maschinen konnten
den beton schutzschild passieren
hätten die vorstellen mit den
beweglichen stahlbeton toren die
druckwelle tatsächlich so ableiten
können dass sie nicht bis in den berg
vorgedrungen wäre schwer zu sagen es kam
mir nie so weit die anlage sollte gegen
eine atombombe geschützt sein wie sie in
hiroshima zum einsatz kam aber seit
damals hatten die waffen deutlich mehr
sprengkraft bekommen
stellen sie sich die ganze logistik vor
in dem berg konnten 1000 leute einen
monat lang überleben super und dann
draußen ist doch alles um sie herum
verstrahlt und dem erdboden gleich gegen
wen sollte noch angriffe fliegen ist
doch alles weg
billig ist der ganze aufwand nicht die
bauarbeiten insel java verschlingen
schätzungsweise 6 milliarden dollar
eines der teuersten bauprojekte europas
dabei ist die unmenge an geld und zeit
die in die grösste flugzeug kaverne
europas gesteckt wird letztendlich für
die katz
[Musik]
1991 bricht ein junges libyen krieg aus
verfeindete truppen kämpfen erbittert um
den stützpunkt
als bosnische truppen drohten das areal
einzunehmen verminte die jugoslawische
volksarmee das gesamte gelände
die serben sprengten startbahnen und
stollen der stützpunkt wurde völlig
zerstört
im tatsächlichen gefechts betrieb war er
nur rund ein jahr
angesichts der enormen kosten und der
tatsache dass der stützpunkt nur anfang
der 90er jahre im jugoslawischen
bürgerkrieg gegen das eigene volk
genutzt wurde kann man das ganze
unterfangen als eine der größten
militärischen fehlinvestitionen
betrachten
die verwaiste anlage ist
lebensgefährlich im gelände um die
stadtbahnen lauern zahlreiche minen die
tunnel sind zum teil mit krebserregenden
stoffen verseucht nur wenige besucher
wagen sich hier hinein
war entstand in der paranoiden ära des
kalten krieges es wurde jahrzehntelang
so ein großes geheimnis darum gemacht
dass man es jetzt nicht einfach zu einer
touristenattraktion umfunktionieren kann
so etwas muss gründlich und äußerst
vorsichtig geschehen denn das hier ist
lebensgefährlich
anlagen wie der koloss von prora die
winzige komplett zugebaut insel hat
china sowie die verwilderten straßen von
pripjat und das tunnelnetz werk insel
java zeigen was bauingenieure alles aus
dem boden stampfen kann
[Musik]
[Applaus]
geister orte wie diese hinterlassen bei
uns ein mulmiges gefühl
was ist dort schief gelaufen könnte so
etwas erneut passieren man bekommt so
eine ahnung wie die welt nach der
apokalypse aussehen könnte
einige dieser verlassenen orte erwachen
langsam wieder zu neuem leben
ich finde es faszinierend dass die
wohnhäuser auf hashima schon vor
jahrzehnten diese fast futuristisch
anmutenden verbindungs stege in der luft
hatten
ist das ein blick in die vergangenheit
oder in unsere zukunft die
weltbevölkerung nimmt rasant zu man
bekommt einen eindruck wie wir mal leben
könnten aber auch wie wir vielleicht
untergehen
in pripjat bieten geführte touren einen
einblick in eine stadt die in der sowjet
zeit stehen geblieben ist die messung
der strahlung am ende bietet einen extra
gruselfaktor
es geht dabei nicht um voyeurismus
die besucher sollen begreifen wie das
damals passieren konnte heutzutage
trauen die leute den medien nicht mehr
verschwörungstheorien haben
hochkonjunktur und das befeuert die
fantasie der menschen
es würde mich wundern wenn die
evakuierung von pripjat nicht als
vorlage für künftige
katastrophenschutzpläne dienen würde die
räumung der gesamten stadt gelangt doch
sehr schnell
[Musik]
aber die meisten chancen doch noch eine
erfolgsgeschichte zu werden hat das alte
nazi projekt
immer wieder gab es pläne dass beton
monster hat zu reißen nun werden die
blöcke nach und nach in luxus
ferienwohnungen umgewandelt und einer in
ein fünf-sterne-hotel
für bauherren ist das ziemlich
verlockend einem alten gebäude einen
neuen zweck zu geben vor allem wenn es
eine so bewegte vergangenheit hat es ist
sehr befriedigend dem ganzen ein völlig
neues image zu verpassen
ein neues image das klingt verheißen
solange die dunkle geschichte hinter der
neuen sonnenseite von prora darüber
nicht in vergessenheit gerät